now I'm gonna guess that you guys are
pretty good at souls games if you like
the game enough to watch this channel
but even the most avid Souls player will
have missed some of the hidden things in
the iron crown DLC I guarantee it
there's some damn good ones here so
let's get a tally going and play the
game that we play on this channel if you
make it all the way through the video
and know everything leave a dislike and
if you learn something new then you feel
free to leave a like so number one has
to do with sir Rowland and his death
animation if you kill him regularly
while taking damage like a normal person
he'll simply kneel down and die but if
you're a Dark Souls God and you take no
damage during the entire fight then
he'll commit sudoku and he'll kill
himself out of shame this is also the
special move of the weapon he gives you
and this is a really really fun
challenge a lot of twitch streamers were
attempting it last week and I was
watching them fail over and over again
and I reckon you should give it a go to
see if you can do it it's like a badge
of honor one tip I have is to quit out
of the game after you take damage during
the fight it's a bit cheesy but this
lets you appear outside his boss fog and
restart straightaway meaning you won't
have to run through all the enemies over
and over again but before you make sir
alonne look like a complete scrub you
should treat him with some respect man
come on number two Ilan does a slight
bow of his head before he rushes to
strike you and to me it really
reinforces the idea that he's
recognizing you as an opponent this guy
is very much into honor a big rumor
circulating was that he would only nod
his head if you bow to him too but
that's not true he does it regardless of
whether you bow or not but you should do
a little role-playing and bow anyway
when you both bow it feels less like a
boss fight and more like you're
challenging an old friend and I think
since you're about to do this challenge
where you don't take damage bowing is
the least you can do number three is
similar to number two it relates to an
old friend turned enemy I'm talking
about the story of rain and his brother
velstadt Raymondville start were known
as the left and right arms of King
vendrick until their wills clashed with
one another the two of them fought
against each other perhaps because they
both believed in a different
of the truth rain the darker brother
lost dispirited and exiled from the
kingdom he once knew he came to broom
tower in search of greater strength and
he found it where before he served this
regal father figure in the king now his
strength comes from a newfound mother
the queen of the dark tower who gave him
true purpose I don't know why I'm
explaining this here though I guess I
just kind of like the law maybe you guys
know that about me already anyway the
third thing you might have missed is
related to this story if you wear the
armor of velstadt specifically the helm
rain will become enraged instead of
entering his second phase at 50% health
he will immediately transition to his
powered up mode as soon as he sees you
wearing those starts gear this might be
useful if you prefer facing his
two-handed sword though I doubt that's
most people because that sword that sort
is brutal number four is a little less
exciting though it's definitely
something you might have missed every
time you destroy an ashen Idol it will
speak a new line of text with 11 in
total they're hard to make out but if
you want to know what she says then
again watch the story mode segments for
this area
seriously it's interesting unrelated
note this though after you collect all
twelve fragments of Natalya a message
will pop up alongside her completed soul
telling you that Natalya is no more true
soul of Natalya
acquired after this you can trade her
soul for either outcry which is kind of
like the firestorm spell or you can
trade her soul for a chime of screams
which will make you scream with rage as
you cast at a startling rate of three
spells per minute last but not least is
the array of hidden doors hidden in the
old iron king DLC there are six in total
this first one is stupidly obvious and
gives you two soul vessels it's right
after the second dashing idol as if you
missed it the second is up on this
inaccessible shelf near the third ashen
Idol it's not really a hidden door it's
just a door that's hard to open you'll
notice that there are black barrels
blocking the door if you look at it from
this angle and it won't open until
they're smashed by hitting the door you
destroy the barrels through it and open
the door to kill this one enemy yeah all
that for one enemy who throws these fire
bombs that barely even hit you
the third is on the elevator that looks
like this
you spam the interact button as you ride
up it on the way to the hidden door and
you go through it on your way down
inside is the hollow skin headpiece
which makes you practically immune to
curse damage when worn
ah poor nashandra she just became even
easier the next three involve hurting
goofy barrel men to their deaths look
out for these brittle walls as you play
there's one here in this long corridor
containing a dispelling ring there's two
in the corridors surrounding the gated
area with black barrels one contains
Katarina gloves and leggings adding on
to the first part of the set found in
the sunken ground DLC and the last
hidden door contains eight count'em 8
petrified dragon bones which is pretty
awesome
so click here if you want to listen to
the story of this area but other than
that thank you so much for taking time
out of your day to watch this and I'll
see you next time